The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: As we come
close to testing, we
have shrinkage here.
People probably left home.
Hopefully, everybody who left
home finished their report.
So you guys have all
looked into how to
do the final project.
And have all the ideas how
to go and optimize.
How many people have downloaded,
compiled, and ran,
and you know what's going on?
OK.
Good.
Exactly.
It's happening right now.
OK.
Good.
So I will repeat this what
I said last time in here.
We're going to have a design
review with your masters.
So just look for us to send
you the information.
That means when you
come back from
Thanksgiving, schedule it early.
So they can help if you have any
changes in design process.
And then we have a competition
on December 9 in class here,
trying to figure
out who has the
fastest ray tracer created.
And in fact, this year there
is Akamai prize for the
winning team, including they
have a kind of celebration and
demonstration in their
headquarters.
You get to go get a tour with
their knock and stuff like.
Plus, every winning member is
going to get a iPod Nano.
So there's a lot more motivation
now to get the
fastest running ray tracer OK.
So with that, let's switch
gears a little bit.
So today, I'm going to talk
about distributed systems.
Until now what we looked at was,
OK, given a box how to
get something running as fast
as possible inside that box.
And today we're going to look
at going outside the box.
Basically, we want to scale up
to clusters of machines.
That means the room can
have 10, 15 machines.
In fact, for your class,
you guys are using--
how many machines do we have?
16 machines.
So you are doing
independently.
But you can use as one gigantic
machine if you can
and run something.
And data center scale.
This is kind of people like
Google, and Amazon, has these
kinds of things.
And finally, Planet Scale.
If you want to run something
even bigger, larger.
What you have to deal with, and
what kind of issues you
have to deal with.
It's time to reboot
my machine.
And I have to be pressing this
button probably four or five
times during the day.
So Cluster Scale.
So you want to run a program
on multiple machines.
And OK, Let me put it there.
Why the heck do you
want to do that?
What's the advantages of--
instead of running on one nice
machine, running on a cluster
of machines?
What do you get?
AUDIENCE: It's cheaper.
PROFESSOR: It's cheaper.
That's a good one.
It's cheaper to get a bunch of
small machines than to buy a
humongo mainframe
type machine.
Yes, that's a very
good answer.
What else?
AUDIENCE: It's very slow.
It's slower.
PROFESSOR: So you would run
something because it's slower?
AUDIENCE: But it
is a trade-off.
PROFESSOR: Yes, so there's some
trade off between speed.
But it might not be that much.
Even when you get a gigantic
machine, there are
bottlenecks in it.
In a cluster kind of thing, you
can avoid the bottlenecks.
But hopefully, you're trying
to do it to get some
performance in scaling
to large number of
users and what not.
So basically, what you
want to get is--
so get more parallelism.
Because now we have more
machines, more calls.
And hopefully get higher
throughput.
Definitely, because
you are doing it.
Hopefully, it's a little bit of
lower latency too, because
if you have one gigantic system,
if everything has to
go through bottlenecks, it might
be slower than basically
having different system.
So assume, just an example, if
you are something like Verizon
or Netflix trying to
serve your videos.
It makes much more sense to have
a bunch of clusters of
machines each doing a lot of
independent work than trying
to send all the videos
to one machine.
Another interesting fact
is robustness.
So until now you guys didn't
care about robustness, because
something went wrong, the
entire thing collapsed.
There's no half baked machine.
The machine crashed, your
program crashed.
Everything died.
So you just have this
fatalistic attitude.
OK.
It crashed.
Everything is dead.
So why bother?
But in these clusters, if you
have a lot of machines, if one
machine dies, there's many
others to pick up.
So you can have a system that
probably has availability much
higher than what you can get
on a single machine.
And finally, cost savings.
Because it's cheaper
to do this, have a
bunch of small machines.
And businesses like Google
has really taken
advantage of that.
So there are issues we have to
deal with in order to program
this damn thing.
And if you want to get
performance, you have to
program in a way to get
good performance.
You don't run much slower
and load less
performance than one box.
You'll get performance and also
performance scalability.
That means if you get 10
machines, you want to get some
performance as if you have 20.
Hopefully, you want to get a lot
more performance than 20.
So how do we keep things
scaling in there?
And also the thing's
robustness.
So the idea there is if you
have one machine, you're
fatalistic.
If the machine goes,
everything goes.
You don't care.
But if you have a lot more
machines, you want to make
sure that application runs even
if the machine's fails.
Worse, if you have a lot of
machines, there's a lot more
chance of failure.
So if one goes down, everything
crashes still.
Then your application will be a
lot less robust even than a
single machine, because
there too many
moving parts to go wrong.
So you want to actually deal
with this robustness.
So that adds an entire new
dimension in there.
We are not going to go too much
deeper into robustness.
But that is one big thing that
you have to really worry about
when you go to distributed
systems.
OK.
What's a distributed system?
So this is what we have
been working so far?
Can we see if we can
reduce the lights?
I guess up there you can't--
OK.
We don't go fully
dark, we'll see.
Oh, that's you guys.
Don't go to sleep even
though light is--
there.
So this should be over there
and I don't have any way to
darken this side.
So these are the machines we
have been thinking about.
We have a memory system.
And more than just having
a shared memory,
we have cache coherence.
So that means if two people want
to communicate to write
to this single memory location,
and the lot of that
data appears lower on all
the different cores.
So we can use that information
to basically communicate to
the processor.
That's really nice.
So a distributed memory machine
has no shared memory.
So each memory is--
Now, how are you going
to communicate?
Message?
Yeah, this is not software.
You actually need something
additional.
Something like a network, or
Internet, something behind
sitting out that actually
let you communicate
between each other.
So if you just really look at
the kind of cost, this is a
back of the envelope
type calculation.
Register is probably
one cycle.
Cache is about 10 cycles.
If you go to DRAM, you can
get about 1,000 cycles.
Remote memory, going somewhere
across, is, again, another
order of magnitude from that.
So of course, you keep adding.
And that's probably the
reason that sometimes
things can be slow.
Because now, we have another
layer that's even slower.
So we have to think about it,
worry about it when you're
writing code for these
types of machines.
So in shared memory machines,
we learn in
languages like Cilk.
It's very nice to communicate
because we
synchronize via locks.
And all communication
via memory.
Because when you write
something, if you look at that
memory location, everybody
else will see it.
And if you put the right
synchronization, hopefully you
will get the value you want.
In distributed memory
machines, there's
nothing like that.
So what we see is we explicitly
sends some data across.
So you have what we
call messages.
And that means if you want to
send something to-- if another
person needs to look at
something, we have to send it
to that person.
So you have to originate
yourself.
Saying, I'm sending.
That other person has
to receive it.
And they have to put it
wherever you want.
So everybody's address
space is separate.
And if you want to synchronize,
you would also do
it through the message.
So you send a message, then the
other person wait for the
message to come.
And so this shows you what
normally happens in messages.
In the shared memory, there's
nothing called message size.
You write a cache line.
The cache line moves.
And you can't keep changing
the cache line size.
Hopefully, prefetcher will be
good and do something nice.
But you don't have
that much choice.
In messages, you can compose any
size of message you want.
So what this graph shows is the
minimum cost and average
cost of different
size messages.
So there's a couple of things
to get out of this graph.
One is that if the message is
even 0 length, or very small,
you still have overhead.
You're going to send
the darn message.
So if even you send nothing,
it cost you some amount.
And the second thing is as the
message gets bigger and
bigger, the cost keeps
increasing, because now you're
sending more and more data.
So if you really amortize the
overhead cost, you are to send
large messages in there.
Another thing this chart shows
is that as messages become
bigger, the kind of the
distribution of overhead is
all over the map.
Because now we are sending large
things, a lot of other
craziness happens
to these things.
So sometimes it can go
fast, sometimes it
can be pretty slow.
I will get why it might be
sometimes this kind of
distribution shortly.
So the main point is that, that
you don't send smaller
messages if you can, because
the overhead is too high.
So why is this?
Why is sending messages
complicated?
Till now, there's
nobody sitting
between you and hardware.
Once you send the program run,
you own the entire hardware,
and after figuring out all the
weirdness that's on x86
there's nothing in
between you.
You probably won't look at the
compile code if you look at
what assembly is generated
you have full view
what's going on in here.
Unfortunately, message passing,
a lot of other things
come into play.
So if you want to send a message
and the applications
says, aha, I'm sending
a message.
And normally, it will
do a system call
to operating system.
And normally, this message
will get copied into the
operating system.
It's copying here.
This operating system called the
operating system wakes up.
This might be when this
scheduled, there's a lot of
things going on.
And then the operating system
has to send to the network
interface card.
And the network will say, OK,
I can't send long messages.
I'm going to break into a
bunch of small messages.
And put some hardware here.
And it will end up in
the other side.
In a bunch of fragmented small
pieces that the network
interface unit has to reassemble
into one message
and deliver up.
And this will probably--
it will copy back into
the application.
So what that means is that a
lot of other things getting
involved, each optimize
separately, doing a lot of
different things.
And so that is why you have this
big unpredictable mess
happening in message passing.
And so there you not only have
to worry about your code.
You have to worry about what the
operating system is doing.
You have to worry about what
the network is doing.
You have to worry about your
network card's doing.
So there's a lot of moving
parts in this.
If you want to get really,
really good performance,
people have to worry about
all these things in here.
So let's look at how
a message works.
So I hope you can see
these diagrams.
Can you see these?
Barely?
So let me say--
So I have a sending process
and a receiving process.
Oh, don't reboot please.
And so what happens if-- this
is a message-- if we are
sending without any buffering of
a message, that means I am
not copying it anywhere,
so assume I
want to send a message.
I said I have a message
to send.
And then what happens in this
model is, OK, until the
receiver is ready,
you have to wait.
Because there is no place
to send the message.
So finally, when the other side
says I want to receive
something, it will tell this
thing it's OK to send.
And it will copy the data.
And then after copying the data,
both parts can continue.
So this is what happens if
sender wants to send early.
If you're very lucky, the minute
you try to send, the
receiver says I want it.
And we have very little delay.
And everything gets copied.
And that's in your lucky case.
In other cases, the receiver
wants some data.
But the sender is not ready, so
your receiver has to wait
until the sender wants
to send it.
And when this message [? is ?]
[? sent ?], you copy
the data in here.
So this is a very naive
simple way.
What can we eliminate
out of this?
How can we make it a
little bit faster?
AUDIENCE: Buffer.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
If you buffer, what
will eliminate?
What will go away?
Out of-- we have this overhead,
this overhead, and
this overhead.
Which overheads can
get eliminated?
Wait for send can go ahead.
So what happens is--
So here actually what they're
showing is buffering also with
some hardware support.
That means I am trying
to send something.
And the minute I copied
it out there, I can
keep working in there.
And somewhere in the background
where you send the
data, it will arrive here.
And if it wants it,
the data is there.
Of course, if the receiver comes
early and asks for data,
you can't do that.
Still you have to wait, because
the data is not there.
However, if there's no hardware
support, both has to
probably wait a little bit,
because you have to get the
data copied.
So if you have a lot of hardware
support, you don't
see this copy time.
But if there's no hardware
support, you see some copy
time going in here.
So what's the advantage
of this versus--
OK, tell me one advantage
of this
method versus this method.
So of course, this one there
is a lot of wait time and
stuff like that.
We know that.
But is there any advantage of
doing this one, this waiting
until sending and sending it
there versus this kind of a
nice sending it in
the background.
AUDIENCE: They're
synchronized.
PROFESSOR: Hmm?
AUDIENCE: Sychronized.
PROFESSOR: Synchronized
is one advantage.
What else might happen?
So what else are you going
to do to get this
kind of thing working?
So in order for this to make
progress, what do you have to
do to data?
It has to copy.
So it has to get multiple
copies.
So from application space.
It has to get copied to
operating system space.
It has to get copied into
the networking stack.
So data keep getting copying,
and copying,
and copying in there.
And in here you basically
don't copy.
You just say, OK, wait.
I'll keep the data and when
you're ready, I will send it
directly in here.
And you can directly probably
even send it to the network.
And send it.
So if you're sending a lot of
data, copy my old value.
So this might even be better
if you're sending a huge
amount of data.
So that's one advantage of
having system like that.
And of course, hardware--
if there's no hardware support,
basically still you
have to do some copying
in here.
So this is--
what am I showing here?
So what we are showing in
here is non-blocking.
So one way to look at that is
when you're sending, when you
request for send, what you can
say is, OK, I continue but I
haven't copied the data.
I have my data in here,
but I'm doing that.
But what I must tell you, OK,
look, this data still hasn't
moved out of my space yet.
So I have to worry.
I can't rewrite the data.
And at some point, when you say
I want the data, it will
go there and bring
the data for you.
And catch you like that.
So between this time since I
don't want to make too many
copies, I have to make sure that
I don't touch that data.
Or I have to copy it.
So that's my request in here.
And of course, if you have no
hardware support, you have to
put some time into actually
doing the copying.
So this is nice.
But we want to have a little
bit of high level
support to do this.
So this is not as nice as things
like Cilk, because you
don't have to worry about a
lot of other interesting
things going on.
So what people have developed
is called MPI language,
Message Passing Interface
language.
It is kind of a bit foggy.
But that's the best people
have these days.
A machine independent way of
when have the distributed
systems to communicate
with each other.
So--
[PHONE RINGING]
Whoops.
That's not good.
My phone.
Sorry about that.
So what happens is each machine
has its own processor,
it's own memory.
So there's no shared memory
on a thing like that.
Its own thread of
control is run.
And each process communicates
via messages.
And there is send
as is needed.
And that means but you can't
send like pointers, because
there's no notion of pointers.
You actually have a data
structure that's
self-contained center
of the site.
So here's a small program.
I'm going to walk
through that.
So I have main.
And I'm setting a bunch
of these variables.
For now, those are not
that important.
But for completeness,
I have that.
And then, of course, if use
something like MPI, there's a
bunch of setup things
that you have.
And so basically like cut and
paste with what people
normally do as we set up.
And then I have this
piece of code.
This piece of code, what it
does is, this same program
runs on multiple different
machines.
So everyone has the
same program.
But then at some point,
I want to know in my
machine what to do.
So what I do is I
check who am I?
Am I machine zero?
If I'm machine zero, do this.
If I'm machine one, do this.
So by doing that, I can
cite a piece of code
that everybody runs.
And everybody figures
out who they are.
And if they are the given
thing, what to do.
So here what it says is, OK, if
I'm machine zero, my source
and destination is
machine one.
If I'm machine one,
my source and
destination is machine zero.
So I'm trying to communicate
between each other.
So if you look at what happens
is, first, I am sending
basically to this machine.
So I'm sending something into
this machine, so the syntax--
I'm not going to go
through that.
You don't have to know that.
But what you need to
know is that I'm
trying to send something.
I tell explicitly who to send.
And there has to be matching
receiving that data.
Otherwise, sends go somewhere.
And just it goes bad.
Send here, you can send it.
It can probably go bad.
But receive you have to have
somebody who sends for that.
So the receive basically
has to have matching.
And then you send it
that direction.
And then what I do is
I receive in here.
And this gets sent
to me in here.
So question I did send
receive here.
What would happen if I did
also send receive here?
If I reorganized these two,
what would happen?
If I used the same piece of
code, that two pieces of code.
Then I don't even have
do a bit to make this
two separate code.
I can basically factor
this out down here.
I do a send, receive;
send, receive here.
And then send the just IDs.
What happen?
AUDIENCE: It works
without a buffer.
PROFESSOR: These things
are what you
called blocking sends.
If you have blocking sends, it
means that until the receiver
receives it might be
blocked if you are
doing a blocking send.
OK.
That means if two guys
are trying to
send, nobody is receiving.
You have what?
AUDIENCE: Deadlock.
PROFESSOR: You have deadlock.
So that's why I actually
had to do this.
This is called blocking send.
So instead of blocking sends--
So of course, those are
finalized things
and do that up there.
I can do this one.
What this says is--
This is actually a little
more complicated.
What I'm doing is I have a
bunch of buffers here.
I have how many processors?
I have bunch of buffers
in here.
I have, I guess, my ID number
of processors--
no, numtask number
of processors.
What I am sending, say I'm
sending a circular buffer.
I'm sending around
to everybody.
Both directions.
So I am sending the
previous and next.
So assume something is
sitting in numtasks.
I am sending back and forth.
So here what I am doing is
basically non-blocking sends
and receives.
So first time issuing
a receive.
So even if I receive a receive,
it says I have intent
to receive.
But I am not receiving
something.
I am not waiting.
So I can continue.
And then I am doing the same.
So otherwise, if I just do just
receive and send, if you
do blocking is going
to be deadlocked.
But here I do that.
And then in this wait for all.
What it says is, OK, now
I issued a receive.
Now wait until that
receive is done.
So before I use the data, I have
to wait for it in there.
And also, when I do the send,
I am wait for all in here.
So why do you think it might
be advantageous to do a
non-blocking receives and
non-blocking sends?
So sends, it makes perfect
sense, because once I have
sent, I won't do anything
because I don't have to wait
for anything.
I am done.
So blocking sends is
not that useful.
But receives, why do you want
to do non-blocking receives,
then a blocking receive?
Because then you
won't receive.
You have to wait till the data
comes to do anything.
Because that's what non-blocking
receives means.
I have to receive early and then
wait for the receives to
happen at this point.
What might be an advantage of
doing a non-blocking receive?
Anybody can think
of an advantage?
It's harder.
Because now you have to remove
the receives from the
synchronization point instead
of writing one receive.
AUDIENCE: Because when sends
come from other machines, we
can receive it.
PROFESSOR: That might be one
interesting thing because you
are expecting multiple
receives.
You don't know what's
coming first.
If you do non-blocking receive,
then you can be--
opt out the first guy then
basically work on.
That's a very good point.
OK.
What else?
What other advantages
you might have?
Having a non-blocking receive?
AUDIENCE: If the receive fails,
we can just have them
resend it again.
PROFESSOR: Receive fails?
OK.
Receive fails.
See, that's complicated.
But another interesting
thing might be space.
Because when I see the
non-blocking receive, I know
where the data has to be.
So I already allocated
a buffer for that.
So, if the data comes now, I
can directly copy into my
local buffer if there's already
a received issued, if
there's already a
space allocated.
Normally, other way around,
until you see the issue the
received, you don't know where
the data has to be, so it has
to get copied at that point.
So here, you can keep the
buffer, and hopefully, if you
are lucky, the same hasn't
happened yet, so you should
set up the buffer, and then,
when the data comes, say, aha,
here is the matching receive.
Directly put it there
by passing it and
copying in the middle.
So that's the advantage here.
So, I am here.
I did a wait for the
receives here.
Did the work that
uses the data.
And wait for sends
here, afterwards.
OK.
Could I have moved wait for
sends before the work?
What happens if I have
moved wait for
sends before the work?
Is it incorrect?
How many people think
this is incorrect?
Is it incorrect to move
this wait for sends?
All the sends before the work,
to move this item about?
Because work is where all the
work happens, I assume, that
uses this data.
So wait for sends about
what happens.
AUDIENCE: Well, if that's
incorrect, then you lose...
PROFESSOR: Yeah, you lose--
you're waiting for something
that you don't have to wait.
Of course, you can move these
down, because that means you
might start using, and try to
use data that's not there.
So, this has to be here.
And this, basically,
for performance
purposes, has to be after.
So, of course you have to
worry about a lot of
correctness issues.
One is deadlocks.
So, there are two types
of deadlocks.
That's blocking sends
and receives,
what we talked about.
But there's also other types
of deadlocks that happen
because of resources.
So, let me get to that
in the next slide.
And the other interesting
thing that can
happen is stale data.
In your shared memory machine,
need to update the data.
You know everybody's
going to see that.
Because the hardware
takes care of that.
But, in a message passing
machine, it's up to you get
the latest data when
it's needed.
So, if you don't have the data,
you think, aha, I have
the data, but it might not be
the right value because you
haven't gotten something new.
So, it's up to you to
basically send the
data out and that.
And, also, robustness is a big
issue because the fact that
you have multiple machines means
you can make it robust,
but the other flip side is up
to you to make it robust.
So that means you have to figure
out if a machine fails,
how to respond to that.
So, if you're waiting for a
machine there for it fails.
OK?
There are a lot of issues, it
time out, and then you have to
go and deal with that.
So, that can make the
programming a lot more
complicated.
And if you just don't do that,
your overall program would be
a lot less robust than a single
machine because there
could be a lot more failures
in the large system.
So, here's a kind of deadlock
that can happen.
What I am doing is processor
zero is sending and processor
one is sending data
to each other.
It doesn't have a read write
deadlock because I am for
sending, sending and then I
am receiving, receiving.
The sends here, and the receives
from here, the sends
here, and then receive.
So normally it looks like I'm
sending two things, It should
go, and I am receiving that.
But, assuming that I am sending
huge amount of data.
OK.
So I start sending,
and there's not
enough room for received.
Just say, OK, I don't have any
room to receive, I have to
wait until the data, at least a
data start getting consumed
to start receiving.
OK.
If you keep sending multiple of
send outs, you might do a
multiple of send outs in more
than one, multiple of sends
here, I might get deadlocked,
I might get blocked because
they can have receive, receive,
and he's also trying
to send multiple things, I might
get blocked in here.
So I might get into this
criss-cross situation.
If you were trying to send
something, but other guy can't
proceed, up to get received.
So even though, if program
look like there's a nice
matching send and receive,
there's no cycles.
There's a cycle created by the
resource usage in here.
So, if doing lot of sends before
a lot receives, and
vice versa, you have
to be careful.
If you do too much of that,
it's nice to block things,
move things up.
But if you have too many things,
then you might end up
in deadlock situation.
Even though, traditionally,
it might not happen.
So, you have host of other
performance issues
that you'll deal with.
So let me address couple
of them and what
it might shows up.
So one big thing is
occupancy cost.
Because, when you do shared
memory, minute you basically
showing instructions.
Instruction goes executes, you
are done with and that
operation is finished.
When you are doing a message
passing, each
message is very expensive.
It has to do a lot of things.
You have to do a context switch,
do a buffer copy, and
a protocol stack processing,
and then might have to do
another context switch
for that.
And there's a lot of these
copying and stuff happening,
and the network controller might
interrupt the private
system, because either there's
data coming, copy the data in
there, and you send as
ignored application.
So there's this huge amount
of things happening
just for one message.
If you are sending like one
lousy byte, or one even like
kilobyte., it just doing a lot
of millions of instructions,
just on behalf of small
amount of data.
So that's a large
amount of cost
associated with that overhead.
So, setup already
is very high.
And, so what you want to do is
you want to amortize the cost
by sending large messages.
So what you were to say, so
look I'm not sending this
small thing, I'm going to
accumulate a lot of things,
I'm going to send everything
as bulk if you can.
And then you can basically
amortize these
costs of doing things.
Other thing is communications
is excruciatingly slow.
So even the memory system, it's
about probably a couple
of hundred plus compared
to CPU communicating.
In the cluster interconnect, you
can do tens of thousands
of instructions in the CPU, by
the time it get communicated.
In a grid, or if you are doing
through the internet, and then
it sits in the seconds now.
You can actually feel it.
And then your processor can run
millions of instructions
in that time.
And so if you are waiting for
something, you had to wait for
a very long time.
They might not have enough
things to stuff in the middle,
to kind of amortize the cost.
And then you have to
worry about that.
So what that means is if you
start waiting for something to
happen, you are waiting
for a long time.
So you have to figure out
putting things in there.
Not waiting this, non-blocking
things is very important
because of that.
And so normally what you want
to do is you want to have
always split operations, that
means you want to kind of
initiate something at some
point, very early on, and then
use it later, especially if
you're looking for something
like a receive.
So if, I want to, especially
if I want to get some--
normally in the shared memory,
just kind of doing a simple
thing, asking something and
get replies, very simple.
Here, because if you just do
that, there's a huge waiting
bit rate, so you want to kind
of do speed operations.
So, this code can be
very complicated,
because you tried to--
if you want to ask something,
you ask very early, you do a
lot of other things before
the reply comes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Oops.
OK.
Let's see how many times
I had to press that.
Before I realize I
have to reboot.
So, if you want to
rendezvous with--
normally, what have that means
that two points has to kind of
synchronize at the same point.
So what you want to do is you
can do a three-way sender send
a request, receiver acks with,
OK, it's OK to send, and the
senders delivers the data.
So that means I have to do a
three-way communication.
Or, this alternative with
two-way, you sender doesn't
send anything, receiver
basically send a request, and
then you send the data.
So this could be faster because
there's less things to
do in here.
There's another method called
RMA, or it's another name you
might see, it's called
active messages.
Where you don't ask
the receiver.
When you send, you have some
pre-assigned place you can go
and dump the data.
So you don't wait for somebody
to ask for data.
You said, OK, if I want send,
I'll immediately send, and put
it somewhere.
And the data that I send
the place in here.
So, the first slide I showed
you, all at that time, you saw
all these big difference in
the time, either this can
happen, the message can go very
fast, or sometime it will
be really slow.
There's a big variation
in here.
This happen basically because of
the network communications.
How many of you know a
little bit about TCP?
OK.
Let me just explain about
five minutes of TCP
before I move on.
So TCP is one of the main
protocols that we use to
communicate over Internet.
And two things, you want
to actually send data.
But also, you want to
be a good citizen.
You have actually work in a
way that it doesn't really
take over the entire shared
bandwidth you have.
So what TCP does,
it has a window.
So what it says is, OK, I can
send certain amount of data
that's the size of the window,
but I can't move beyond that
until I get some
acknowledgement.
So I send the window
amount of data.
And, on the other side, when
it's received that data, I
said, I have seen this
much of the window.
And once it's seen this much of
the window this send that
acknowledgement back.
And when that acknowledgement
comes, you
say, aha, that's good.
That means it has seen that.
Then I can send more.
I keep sending more.
And then, the TCP has this very
interesting property.
If you are doing a really good
communication, things are
going very nicely, it starts
increasing the window size.
It says, oh, OK, that means that
windows size keeps going.
I can do bigger and bigger
and bigger window size.
You can keep increasing
the window size.
And then, what happens at some
point, the system get
overloaded, because if you
everyone is start--
increase their window size, too
many packets start coming
into the network.
At some point, the network in
the middle, doesn't have
enough room.
It drops something.
So, TCP, nice thing about the
network is that, even if it
doesn't have a guarantee that it
will guarantee it can just
drop something.
And when it drops, what happens
is the other guy is
waiting for acknowledgement.
So waiting for data to come,
it never shows up.
So then it has this thing, an
ack, saying I never got it.
And the problem with that is, so
you have a nice bandwidth,
and you get increasing the
bandwidth, you get faster and
faster and faster, and suddenly
data get missed.
And suddenly you have this
big timeout delay.
And then everybody freezes.
And then get the ack, and you
restart with a smaller window
and slowly pick up, something
like that.
So because of that, there a lot
of times what happens, is
this packet get dropped,
retransmit happens, so you
have this kind of sawtooth
pattern.
Things get faster and faster,
things go down for nothing,
for a little while, again
start again, in here.
So the other way of
communicating is called UDP.
UDP says, OK, if you don't
have any kind of
acknowledgement, or something
like that, I'll just send.
And you, on the other hand,
figure this out whether you
got something or not.
And send information back.
So the network doesn't
participate in any kind of a
balancing act of
communication.
It's end-to-end.
So of course, you can be a
really bad citizen, and say,
OK, I don't care.
I just keep sending huge
amount of data and then
somebody would go well.
But, what people have found is
for things like video, you can
send UPD and kind of
manipulate yourself
end-to-end, can get
much better than
trying to do this TCP.
So the kind of thing is,
even though there's not
acknowledgment, or there's no
real attempt to make sure all
the data goes, UDP sometimes
can get better bandwidth,
because it doesn't drop
packets in here.
So, there's a lot of great
stuff, I mean you guys can
take the networking class and
learn all about the protocols
and stuff like that.
There's really, really cool
stuff in here, so some of you
might actually, next couple of
semesters, learn all about how
these things work.
So I'm just giving you, lot of
performance wise, these are
the issues that you are to worry
about when you are doing
network level things.
OK.
So that's kind of talks about
a little bit about a small
scale, and then if you want to
go to next bigger scale--
why you want to go?
There can be lot more uses.
If you are on something like
Facebook, or Amazon, you have
a lot more users to deal with.
If you are, what's a good
one with a lot of data?
Google Earth, or something
like that.
You have a lot of data.
And you have to deal with all
the data, and that's a good
way to do the scale up.
Or you might have huge amount of
processing you want to do,
for example, the one place a lot
of data and processing is
things like these new basically
telescopes that's
coming about, that has arrays
of hundreds of different
things, so you have huge amount
of data coming from the
telescopes.
And then you could do a huge
amount of processing and that.
So that basically, has broad
data and processing, and in
things like webs, social
networks, and stuff like that,
gives me a lot of data.
So here are some examples of
some things like the airline
reservation system.
It's something, all the airlines
have to assign
millions of planes, flights,
millions of seats
that you deal with.
Things like a stock trading
system that all the trades has
to has to come there, and the
prices has to get calculated,
and then trades has
to get validated.
And, very big analysis, so you
form some kind of global
understanding of what's
going on.
And I'm going to talk about
these two, three things too.
Scene completion and web
search, which probably
everybody knows.
So, yes, this kind of
data, now, kind of a
web analysis example.
So what these guys were trying
to do was, every weekly, troll
151 million web pages, and
get about a terabyte of
information, and analyze
page statistics.
So that's what they
are trying to do.
Some come up with some
idea about OK, what
is the world happening?
How did the pages change
the last week?
And then try to get a
global view of that.
At this point, you have both
huge amount of data and pretty
large amount of computation
power, that you had to build a
system to do that.
This is where you need
a larger system.
Here's another interesting
system that people built.
So if you have image here, and
the image has this nice
background, there's
unfortunate house
sitting in the front.
So what this says is, OK,
eliminate the house, search a
very large database to find
similar images and plop
something in there.
OK.
So OK.
You can get your face with
some nice actual eyes, or
something like that.
Just eliminate all the bad
parts, and then and then get
good parts and put
them in there.
And so this one, basically, what
they'll do was, that's
about 396 gigabytes of
images out there.
And so we had to classify
images to get the scene
detector, do color similarity,
and do context matching.
So computation, what they're
doing is about 50 minutes
doing scene matching, 20 minutes
of local matching
trying to find right matching,
and four minutes composing
there, and then you can
parallelize that and reduce
this time to about
five minutes.
So here's something that's
huge amount of data.
You'll look a lot of things, you
do a lot of processing to
figure out we get the right
thing and these actually keep
increasing these images as we
keep asking for more, more
flexibility, and
more accuracy.
Things can get higher
and higher.
So really cool application that
really require large data
and large processing.
So, of course, the kind of
clinical application is
probably Google.
So in this research, you'll
get some nice results.
So what people say, is this
what two thousand process
involved getting this
query for you.
It takes 200 plus terabytes of
data, but this is already old
now, this could be
even higher now.
And this takes ten to the ten
total clock cycles for
everything that needs
to happen, for you
to get to your query.
And you only get one
sent for the query.
So that, not only are doing it
fast, you are doing a lot of
processing, you are doing
it very cheap.
And I think one of the biggest
things that Google did is
figure how to get that
done fast and cheap.
And that's why they
so successful.
Oops, sorry, I didn't say
this. so it's one second
response time, and the cheapest
$0.05 average the
cost, basically.
If you compute a time that's
going to cost more than $0.05,
is not worth it.
And you had to do it that.
So, this is Google, spend a lot
of time how to figure out,
how to do this is cheaply.
So, this is already validated,
but Google is very secretive
of what they do, so this is the
closest I can figure out.
They have three million plus
processers in clusters of 2000
plus process, each,
in each cluster.
And what they already did
was they went for
the cheapest thing.
They build entire system
out of the cheapest
parts we can get.
x86 processors, the cheapest
disks, fairly cheap
communication, and
gain reliability,
redundancy though software.
So each part, I mean supposing
in Google, this data center,
there's somebody who's
constantly growing and
changing machines and
changing disks.
Because there's so
much failure.
But that means we have to have
the software system to keep
the things running in there.
And what they have is a
partitioned workload, all
those things are nicely
partitioned and distributed
through Google as this nice file
system and stuff do that.
And then you have to do
crawling, index generation,
index search, document
retrieval, ad placement, all
those things happen in there.
Of course, other things like
Microsoft and Yahoo, and all
those other people have
systems like that.
So this is kind of what, when
you go in here to scale up,
there's no other way, you have
to actually build this huge
system to do that.
So one thing Google does, going
a little bit technical,
is this have a system
called MapReduce.
How many of you have seen,
heard of MapReduce?
OK.
So there's all this people
who know MapReduce.
Probably more than I do.
So the idea there is you have a
bunch of data, a huge amount
of data in here.
And, normally, what you have
to do is find some
similarities in lot of
data, and do some
processing for that.
And this is programming model
set up nicely help doing that.
So, that this borrows lot of
functional programming.
What that means is I'm not
changing data, I'm always
taking some data values and
creating something new.
I'm never changing something
existing, that's basically
meaning of a functional
program.
So MapReduce has
two components.
First the map.
That means given some input
value and a key in there, what
you develop generate is some
intermediate results and
output key.
You get bunch of values coming
through, and everybody process
each one as separate.
And say, OK.
So here is the output
key, and here's some
intermediate value.
And then what you do is things
with the same output key gets
sorted into one list.
And then it's going reduce it.
And the reducer takes the output
key in this list, and
say, OK, look I'm going to
process the entire list down
to one element or
small data item.
OK?
So let's go through
a little bit more,
digging deep into that.
And so you map, basically get a
huge amount of records from
the data source, and it fits
into this map function, and it
produce intermediate results.
And the reduced function,
basically, combines the data,
and all the folding--
let me give you an example.
I think that will
show you better.
So here is kind of
architecture.
So you have a huge amount
of data resources.
You have many, many
sources in here.
And each of the data comes in
to that, and the map will
basically distributed by keys
and values, so there could be
millions and values.
And then, what you have to do
is, wait until all the data,
has done that.
And then cleared for
the number of keys
here, number of reducers.
So hopefully you wont
have a lot of keys.
If you have more than two
keys, you don't get that
parallelism because then you
would be too huge lists.
And then, again, what happens
is these keys get paired to
reducers to come the final
value in here.
So what's the parallelism
here?
What makes the parallelism
go high?
Or, not have enough
parallelism?
Yeah, I mean, first of all,
you need to have enough,
hopefully, multiple data stores
so you get a lot of
parallelism coming in here.
Map is easily parallelizable,
because each choosing in here.
Reducer is the problem
I think one.
Because if you have too many
keys, too little keys, you are
in trouble.
The other interesting thing
in here is there's a big
shuffling between here.
So that means data has to
go all over the place.
So it's not something that, you
got data and you process
to the end you got data you
process to end, every data has
to kind of cross back, and so
that's a huge amount of
communication in here that could
be bottle-necked too.
That can be bottle-necked, keys
can be bottle-necked.
So map function runs parallel,
creating different things.
Reduced functions also run
parallel for each key.
And all values are basically
processed independently
because of that.
Also, the bottle-neck is reduce
phase can't start until
all the map is done, and also
all the data gets shuffled
around with that.
So here's an interesting
example.
What I am trying to do is I am
trying to count the number of
words in assume huge amount
of web pages.
So what I can do is in the map,
I get each page in here--
I thread through the page
emitting each word as my key
and the count as one.
Because I only get one thing.
And then my reducer
is basically--
my key is each word.
So if I have a million words, I
can have a million reducers.
And the reducer basically takes
all those things-- it's
not that fun because
everything is
all at number one.
Because we count at one.
And then basically keep adding
up how many things for each
word came about and put
up the results.
So you can say, OK, look, for
the entire corpus of data, I
had this many words count, this
many word occurrences,
this many all for each word.
You get a word count.
So basically trying to create
a histogram here and
MapReducer provides a very nice
interface to do that.
And it's very nice, high level,
and it provides this
nice infrastructure to run this
in parallel in here and
do all the communication
necessary, figure out how many
reducers to run, look at
machines to run them, produce
the result, and give
you the result.
So this is a nice infrastructure
Google has
built in there.
So in this level, when
you go to this--
this is the data center level.
What do you have
to do to scale?
You need to distribute data.
And you need to parallelize
because if all the data is in
one machine, it doesn't help.
And you need to have parallelism
to scale
everything.
Another interesting thing you
can do is approximate.
So what that means is normally
when you calculate, when
everybody has exactly the same
data all the time-- because
when you write the memory,
everybody sees that memory--
you have the perfect knowledge
of the word.
And in a distributed system,
getting perfect knowledge is
very expensive.
That means every time something
changes, you have to
send everybody that data.
And one way that people really
make these systems run fast,
you say, wait a minute, if
somebody doesn't have the
perfect knowledge, if there's
a little bit of discrepancy
between something, I am OK.
Assume you have a new--
you changed your--
we'll say--
web page and added a couple
of new words in there.
Next second, the search
doesn't see it.
Nobody's going to complain.
And then you can deliver that.
If you do a search, you'll
find something.
But somebody else doesn't do it
because that data haven't
propagated that to both
of the things.
Nobody's going to complain and
say, wait a minute, I found
it, but he didn't.
It can have a little
bit of a lag.
And that can be really,
really useful in
these kind of systems.
Because every time something
happened, you don't have to
keep updating.
But tell me a system that you
can't actually do that.
Play it a little bit
fast and easy.
AUDIENCE: Stock trading.
PROFESSOR: Stock trading.
Yeah, that's something
basically, if you say, yeah,
you might get it too,
you might get it--
and that doesn't work.
Basically, stock trading has
this very particular thing
because when it does submit,
we'll say, a sale order,
within a certain amount of time,
it has to get matched up
and has to be announced
to both people.
And also, there are a lot of
other constraints like if the
machine goes down.
Either trade has to be everybody
saw the trade or
nobody saw it.
You can't say-- somebody
says, I sold it.
And another guy says,
no, I didn't buy it.
And when you have millions of
billions of dollars back and
forth, that doesn't
really work.
So for that, there's this thing
called transactions.
So transactions is an
interesting way-- a lot of
databases have this
transaction.
Transactions say, look,
I am doing this
very complicated thing.
And I cannot have this
intermediate state going on.
So what transactions say is,
first, tell me everything I
want to do in the transaction.
So it might be I want to sell
a stock, I want to buy a
stock, whatever.
And then at some point when you
commit the transaction,
you either say, OK, everything
worked, good, the entire thing
gets committed.
And you are done.
Or it can explicitly
reject it.
It can come back and say,
look, I can't do this
transaction.
Now sorry, you can restart it.
So you can accept and reject.
But then the nice thing about
that is then every one
single-- it's like atomicity.
Every one action doesn't have
to happen immediately or
happen as a group.
You can say, OK, I'm doing
a bunch of action in the
transaction.
And then finally, I can come
in and if it works, great.
So what might be a reason you
might not be able to commit a
transaction if you
do a transaction?
Anybody else want to answer?
When you say, I want a
transaction, I want to commit
something, what might say--
so here's an interesting
thing.
In the stock trading
type world--
so assume I want to
sell something.
Let's look at the airline
reservation.
So assume I have an airline
seat in here.
And if two people want to try to
resell that seat, I can do
all this processing in parallel
for everybody until I
come to the commit point.
That means I can look at
everybody after you enter the
data, do the price, all those
things separately
for the same seat.
But then when you come to the
commit point, you say, can I
commit the transaction?
At that point, only at that
point, they have to figure out
whether there's a conflict
in here.
And at some point, if
there's a conflict,
it says, oops, can't.
One transaction has
to get aborted.
The nice thing about that is
most of the time people are
not going to fight for
the same seat.
And then things can proceed
in parallel.
You don't have to wait.
Otherwise, if you do that,
there might only one seat
assignment at a time
you can do.
And that's really not
going to scale.
So everybody tried to
get their seat.
They go to the end, and they
say, can I proceed?
And at that point, you check
whether there's a conflict.
And if there's a conflict,
one guy backs out.
So that's the transaction.
Oops, I'm going to get
rebooted I guess.
So when you go to planet scale,
you can get even into
more issues, things like--
what could be a planet scale
thing out there?
What's an interesting planet
scale thing that
you can think of?
Single computation that has to
happen in the planet scale.
Something like Internet
naming system.
It has to work everywhere
in the entire planet.
Or something like Internet
routing.
There has to be an algorithm
that has to work.
The entire world has to
cooperate and then make sure
that all the traffic actually
goes to the right place.
So there's a lot more
issues, interesting
things show up in here.
So things like Seti@Home
type stuff--
these are a little bit dated
these days, that happens--
distributed all across
the place.
So if you do planet scale, it
has to be truly distributed.
There cannot be any global
operations, no single
bottleneck.
And you have to have
distributed
view with stale data.
You cannot say, look,
everybody has to
have the same data.
You have to have everything
distributed.
And it has to add up to load
distributions because things
can keep changing in there.
So what I'm going to do next is
trying to give you a little
bit of a case study that shows
you some interesting
properties that show
up when you start
building at that scale.
And this has some planet scale
type properties, some cluster
properties, whatever.
And I will probably first
describe this interesting
problem and then show what kind
of solutions that came
through, so to give you
a perspective for
a problem in here.
Any questions up to this far
for distributed systems?
It's hard to do distributed
systems in one lecture.
There are almost closest for
distributed systems.
But this will give you a
feel for some of it.
So the case study here
is from VMware.
It's called deduplication
at global space.
And the problem shows up when
you're trying to move virtual
machines across the world.
You have this virtual machine.
So what virtualization did was
it took a piece of hardware
and it converted
it into a file.
So each machine is now a file.
When you have a file, like
hardware, there are a lot of
cool things you can do then.
You can replicate those files.
So suddenly, instead of one
machine, you've got tens of
hundreds of machines.
You can move those
things in here.
And of course, you can start
another machines all over.
So once you are able to move
these things, the issue
becomes how to move those things
around and what's the
cost of moving something.
And also, you can
store it, store
those things in a database.
The interesting thing that's
happening these
days is cloud computing.
Cloud means there's all these
providers all over the place,
saying, I have processing
power, I can
give you some of them.
Amazon does something easy too,
but Verizon is trying to
do, everybody is trying
to do that.
So if you want to have the best
market, what you want to
do is have the elasticity to
move from cloud to cloud for
many reasons.
So sometimes the cloud
might be too small.
You want to get to a bigger
cloud in there.
Or you want to be
near the users.
So in the daytime in the US, you
want probably to move the
machines through US.
At night, there might be users
in China, so you want to move
your compute nearer China.
Because it will be closer to the
people who are using it.
So something like that, you
can move around there.
Or you want to find the
cheaper provider.
If somebody comes and says,
look, I can give you compute
power $0.10 cheaper than what
you are getting, OK, I want to
move to that guy.
And also, to amortize the risk
of catastrophic failure.
If there's a hurricane
approaching somewhere, I might
want to move to a data center
that might be out of the way.
And I want to do that.
And the interesting thing there
is a lot of things.
But when you say, application in
the cloud, it's a machine,
a machine basically in
a virtual machine.
At the same time, a virtual
machine has to get moved
around, not your small
application.
The entire thing has
to move around.
And virtual machines
are hefty.
Because it has an operating
system,
it has all the software.
There's so many things now.
Then your data and your state.
There are a lot of things
in the machine in here.
And all those things have to get
moved around, so that can
be expensive.
So yes, interesting experiment
in here.
So the idea here is to try to
move something from Boston to
Palo Alto on a 2 megabytes
network.
And there are a bunch
of different virtual
machines in here, VMs.
And it takes--
whatever--
3,000 minutes to move these
machines from--
this is 500 minutes.
That means what?
Some hours to move them.
Some hours to move these
machines around.
And then what you say, look, the
machines are heavy, big.
Why can't you first compress
the machine?
So you can use something like
normal compression.
So blue is basically compress,
move the machine, and
decompress.
So here is something
interesting.
This is a very fast
compression.
You did really well, you
are moving there.
If you want a better
compression, you say, I'm
going to do a full, best
compression I can do, it's
actually slower.
Because the trouble is the
compression time is so high,
the reduction is not
usable in here.
So you try to compress, you
spend most of the time
compressing.
So actually, this is even
slower that just sending
without compression.
So compression is important,
compression is useful.
So can you do better than a
normal compression in here?
How can you do better?
So some key observations
in here.
So a large part of these
files are executables.
You have your Linux kernel,
whatever, to all those
executables hitting in there.
And basically, that's
monoculturing the world.
There are no million different
executables.
You are a Linux kernel, there's
only a certain amount
of versions.
Microsoft XP, there are certain
types of versions.
So even though there are
millions of machines, inside
the millions of machines,
there aren't millions of
different applications.
There's only hundreds of
And so your motion moves.
If you think about it, you are
moving the same thing again
and again and again.
Can you take advantage
of that?
And there's even substantial
redundancy in each of these.
So this is very interesting.
If you have a Windows machine,
each DLL has three copies.
So you have the copy, and then
the Installer has a copy.
And then there's another copy
in the next version to
basically back out,
so undo copy.
So each thing is kept
three copies.
So every big thing,
they're seeing
multiple copies in there.
So that part is there also.
Even within a single disk, there
is redundancy in here.
And another interesting thing
is many of the disks have a
large amount of zero pages.
So if you send something
uncompressed, you send a huge
amount of zeros.
So you are waiting for zeros
to get in there.
Even easy compression can get to
those zeros, but this is a
large chunk of data in here.
And so the interesting thing
is if you take one virtual
machine, this is the number
of non-zero blocks.
And this is the number
of unique blocks.
So unique blocks are smaller
than non-zero blocks.
But if you keep adding more
and more virtual machines,
then of course, the number of
total blocks keeps going up.
But the unique blocks doesn't
keep increasing.
That means the second Linux box
you add, there's not much
new in there.
So if you look at that, what
happens is the first guy has
about 80% things are unique.
When you keep adding things,
it's about only 30% is unique
after you add.
Because it's the same program.
Only the data is different
as you keep adding.
So can you really take
advantage of that?
So that is where deduplication
comes in.
So deduplication says, I have
this data, I have a lot of
redundant data.
So A B, A B, A B is redundant.
So what you want to do is break
it up to some kind of
blocks in here.
And then one easy way to
do is calculate a hash.
Because you don't want
to compare blocks.
That's too much.
N squared comparison of blocks
is a lot of comparison.
You can have some kind of
hash calculated for
each of these blocks.
And then you can compare
the hashes.
And if the hashes are
the same, they
are the same blocks.
And then what you can do is
you can eliminate most of
these blocks in there and then
keep hashes for each block--
only the hash.
And then what you can do is you
can only keep the unique
blocks in here.
So even though you have nine in
here, only five different
unique blocks are there.
So that's a nice way
of deduplicating.
So you actually have what you
call recipe, a common block
store in here.
So one way to do that is you
can have a recipe on common
block store for each of
the systems in here.
That's the tradition
of deduplication.
Or what you can do is have
everybody keep a recipe and
only have one common
block store.
Just keep one, single common
block store, and everybody
have a recipe, or probably
cache of a recipe.
So by doing that, you can even
reduce a huge amount of the
things happening in here.
So the interesting thing is if
you are keeping one common
block store, who can keep,
who can manage?
That's the interesting
question in here.
So can you keep instead of
common block store for each
processor, each computer, can
you keep the common block
store for the entire world?
So if you find most of the
common blocks in the world,
keep one store.
And the nice thing about
that is then I can go
anywhere in the world.
I can ask for the common blocks
for the common things.
I can populate it myself.
So here's this interesting
system called the Bonsai.
What they did was--
so if you have a block in here,
you calculate a hash
function in here,
get a hash key.
So what that means,
the hash key can
uniquely access this block.
And then what you want to do
is ask that you want to
compress this block.
This additional step, I'll
explain later why it's needed.
So the other thing you can do
is you can get a second hash
key and use that as a private
key to encrypt this block.
Because you calculate
two hash keys.
One is the hash key
to identify.
The other one is a private key
to encrypt this block.
And then what you can look at
is this global store to see
whether this hash key exists.
If the hash key exists,
then say, I got the
page, here is the page.
That's the encrypted page.
And each page will
have a unique ID.
And so here's my unique ID.
If you find the page in here,
what you can do is you can
only store UID and this
private key and
get rid of my page.
So storing UID and private key
is sufficient to get my page
and unencrypt it.
Why do you think I have
to compress here?
Why do I have to basically
do encrypt here?
What's the interesting thing
about encryption?
Why encrypt?
Assume this is global.
Because if you don't encrypt, it
might be a common page, but
it might not be something you
want everybody to know.
So assume a large company
like Google.
President of Google, Larry Page,
sends everybody emails,
saying, this is very private,
but here is something that's
happening in the company.
And it will get into everybody's
mailbox.
And suddenly, it becomes--
aha-- a common page.
And it gets sucked in
the world because
of the common page.
And now everybody can see that,
and that's not good.
But now if you have
this private key--
if you don't have the private
key, I can't decrypt that.
So what happens is--
let me go through what
you can do in here.
And then what can happen is if
you had these two, UID and
private key, you can go to the
global storage and say, here's
the UID, give me the page.
It has a page.
It better have the page
for that UID.
Get the page out of that.
And then now I can use my
private key to decrypt it.
And then of course, I
can decompress it in
the original page.
So by doing that, I can have
this global system that keeps
common pages in there
and store them.
I can basically, really
eliminate the storage.
Because the nice thing is this
could be, we'll say, 2K pages.
And this is 64 bit, and this
is probably 256 bit.
So there's a huge compression
of data in there.
So here are the kinds of
decisions you are to make.
For example, hash key.
So each page is represented
by a hash key.
But you can have two hash keys,
two pages mapping to the
same hash key.
So my god, you're not unique.
So why is it OK?
AUDIENCE: Low probability.
PROFESSOR: Very low
probability.
And in fact, what they looked
at was they calculated the
disk failure.
There's a higher failure of disk
failing and losing data
than hash collision.
So you can say, look, you're
keeping that in the hard
drive, so there could be more
chance of disk failure than
hash collision.
So therefore, hash key is--
you can do that, low enough
probability, you can
get away with that.
Actually, I want to skip the
rest of this in there.
So here is the comparison how
much compression you can give.
Some of them, you almost
can compress 100%.
Because if you have a newly
installed Linux box with very
little data, everything
is in the global.
So by doing that, basically,
here is the communication.
The compression is cheap.
You don't have to do too much
because you just do this hash
comparison to do that.
And then now the communication
time is even reduced because
you communicate a lot less.
And then you expand.
So all these three are actually
now much faster to
send a machine across.
So here is a total size
of all the VMs.
The interesting thing is if you
compress within, if you
just do compression, most
of this is zero blocks.
You can eliminate the zeros
and do a simple
compression in here.
And if you do local
deduplication, if you
eliminate that, and
if you do global,
you'll get to this point.
So you get to about basically
30% of all your data.
And yeah, there's more data
in here, but just--
So that's an interesting global
level system that
people are building today.
And I think if these kind of
systems appear in many
different places.
These days, a lot of people are
building things like cell
phone games and things like
that, has this huge back
stores, back computation.
All those things have this large
scalability in there.
And so the nice thing about
performance engineering is if
your application doesn't require
a huge amount of
computation or very fast
processing, if you're going to
have millions and millions of
users, or if you're expecting
millions of users, then building
these systems, and
understanding, and building
scalability is really important.
And a lot of the things we
learned in this class is
directly applicable there.
So I have...
Any other questions before you
guys can go finish your
project report and go have a
nice Thanksgiving dinner?
So everybody is thinking that
they will be able to get a
good handle on what they are
doing for the final project?
Oh come on, there are so many
cool things you can do with
this project.
AUDIENCE: We're working on it.
PROFESSOR: And there are--
whatever--
three or four iPod
Nanos waiting.
So it makes a lot of
sense to actually
really focus this one.
This is a fun project.
This is, in fact,
a fun project.
Because talk to these guys
what they did last year.
People did a lot of interesting
things.
Because we gave you freedom to
actually even change the
algorithms.
So you can actually look
at the algorithm.
If you know a little bit of
physics and graphics type
stuff, look at them and say,
look, can I even reduce
computation of how the
computation is being done?
So people got a lot of wins
by doing things like that.
And of course, parallelization
matters.
And there are a lot of
optimization possibilities in
this piece of code.
So take a look at that.
Just have a plan.
Just don't go blindly into
it, just have a plan.
Run it, profile it,
get some feedback.
You need to get this for
your presentations.
So run, profile, get some
feedback, have a good plan.
Go attack it.
So see you in a week.